what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to hype train yes welcome
back to hype train by the way we
rebranded pop culture explain to geek
culture explain because
it feels like it's more in line with our
brand and we're geeks i know i'm a geek
i've been a geek for 25 years and we
called that
son we called that we call i told
man i told y'all i told y'all i told
y'all we were going to get the young
avengers i told y'all we were going to
get the young
avengers and falcon in the winter
soldier and i saw some of y'all's
comments somebody else's comments like
no rob that's ridiculous that's silly
we're not going to see anybody from the
young avengers let me say something i've
been reading comments for 25 years y'all
do not question the master
right do not question the master
of comic books on youtube all right
here's here's the important thing
here's the thing here's the thing right
here's the thing i'm sorry i'm so
excited people but it is an exciting
moment
here on geek culture explain it is an
exciting moment
here on this hype train show all right
here's the thing here's the thing so
let's do a little bit of explaining here
elijah bradley right there was a story
that was written in marvel comics back
in 2003 called truth red white and black
and it basically retconned in this
notion of a captain america
that we basically just didn't know
anything about now here's here's the
thing behind us right so the idea
is that after steve rogers was frozen in
a block of ice everybody thought he was
dead nobody knew that he was alive they
just assumed he was dead at the very
least he was m.i.a
and then because he went down on the ice
after a while you're just kind of like
okay this dude's probably dead right i
mean like
he went down in the ice no one can
really survive those conditions steve
waters is gone right so what ended up
happening here let's see this this this
man this this is why it pays to read
comics for 25 years son
what ended up happening here is the
federal government was trying to find
ways to create more super soldiers and
so what they ended up doing is they went
down to mississippi and they rounded up
300 african americans this is probably
the reason why they're saying
sam wilson was based out of mississippi
in the marvel cinematic universe instead
of harlem like he was in the comics and
so they they rounded them all up and
they subjected them to a series of
experiments basically to create a new
captain america basically
isaiah was the only one to survive the
experience what ended up happening is he
took up the shield
and then went off to europe to fight in
the war which was considered treasonous
by the us government so they snatched
him up they brought him back they put
him on trial sentenced him
life in prison and then i guess in in
the comics he only served 17 years i'm
guessing in the marvel cinematic
universe from what he said he served
30 right but regardless he was arrested
for essentially crimes or
treason against the united states and
that that was it right but then like
once he was released his entire history
was just swept under the rug and nobody
knew that he was there right like nobody
knew that he was ever a hero and that
was basically it it was it was an
amazing story which we'll probably cover
on comics explain now we kind of have to
right we'll probably cover it on
comments explain but it was it was an
amazing story it was a really really
good story so here's the thing right
here's the important thing behind all
this here's why this matters
isaiah bradley's introduction into the
marvel cinematic universe
this seemingly establishes exactly what
i've been saying the marvel cinematic
universe is going to be doing for quite
some time right
building up superheroes in the
background introducing new characters
because the kid that answered the door
when they went to the went to the dude's
house i can almost guarantee you his
name is elijah and he's patriot in the
young avengers right like so the way
this played out was that after isaiah
came back he ended up having a son
and then his son uh or i guess before he
before he came you know once he got a
serum and everything uh he ended up
passing it on to his son
his son went to go fight in conflicts to
kind of live after his father's legacy
when his son came back he had a son
whose name was elijah and elijah went on
to become part of the young avengers
alongside hulkling and kate bishop and
all those characters that the marvel
cinematic universe has basically said
that we're going to see somewhere along
the line i told you all the young
avengers go back and watch my young
avengers video i told you all this is
going to happen man i told you i was
going to so here's the crazy thing about
elijah
i would surmise that with everything
that went on with isaiah he fought
during the korean war
that seems to be the indication there so
what if we said
that like okay isaiah was fighting
during the korean war isaiah kind of
opens up starts talking to bucky barnes
and talking to sam wilson and just kind
of like
spills the beans right and it's just
like i'm only the tip of the iceberg
right this guy's like deep throat from
watergate right just the facts are
flowing right this guy's like you know
i'm only the tip of the iceberg i'm the
one who became captain america but there
were other experiments that were being
conducted by the federal government well
that gives us weapons plus
just right there boom that gives us
weapons plus those of you guys don't
know what weapons plus is weapons plus
was the project that started with steve
rogers weapon 10 was wolverine right and
then you get the ones after that right
weapon 11 weapon 12 you get like phantom
x the stepford kakoos which is basically
these four girls who are clones of emma
frost from the x-men like you get all
this all this crazy stuff going on but
what if he says
there's a there's a guy that i fought
with like like whatever it is they're
hunting for he's like i don't really
know how to give you the answer to that
but i know a guy who does
who is a superhero that i have been
dying to see
who fought during the korean war is adam
beshear right like that would be adam
brosher and it would be like dude blue
marvel in the mcu i know i'm looking for
reasons to get blue marvel and marvel
cinematic universe i don't apologize
i'm not apologizing for that i want to
see adam brosher in the marvel cinematic
universe and i will theorize any
possible
any possibility of getting him in there
but the important takeaway from all this
when it comes to isaiah bradley yes he's
basically just a version of captain
america that came after steve rogers
that was a result of an experiment by
the federal government it wasn't like
the tuskegee experiments where they were
giving people syphilis and then just
seeing what happened if it went
untreated that's not really what this is
it's like as it kind of is but it was
just an attempt to create new super
soldiers but the cool thing is this can
roll in the idea of weapons plus right
like weapons plus weapon one which was
steve rogers weapon two three four five
six seven eight nine and then going into
weapon ten which is
wolverine right so i've been i've told
y'all man like all this stuff just kind
of ties together like give it time and
it all wraps up and it all comes
together and it all ties together and
it's and it's just it's a it's amazing
stuff but here's the cool thing about
this right this is what makes it so cool
is we know that whatever method that was
used to create the super soldier serum
still exists out there because the flag
smashers are all basically captain
americas it's what sam wilson said to
bucky barnes is what bucky barnes agreed
with sam wilson that like they have
super soldier serum enhancements
increased strength agility speed
different things like that it's all
basically
a whole bunch of steve rogers running
around now how it is that happened
i'm not entirely sure i guarantee
whatever process it is is seemingly
coming out of madrid which is why we're
going to see them going to majapur in
the first place right i mean those of
you guys who don't know major poor is
essentially like the mos
eisley from star wars in the marvel
universe it's where all the villains
hang out at right like anybody who goes
to madrapor
is up to some nefarious stuff like
they're up to no good it's just
bad guys doing bad guys stuff but it's a
it's a cool concept but whatever it
is like i think this is the tip of the
iceberg right what we're seeing with
isaiah what we're seeing with like the
idea that there was another
another captain america out there it's
the tip of the iceberg guys but i think
the important here
the important thing here is to establish
the fact that i was right
god i'm petty i'm such a petty human
being uh i was i was right that's the
important thing but more so than that
[Laughter]
more so than that it really is this
notion that that if there are other
super
other captain americas out there then it
stands to reason if they can duplicate
the super soldier serum then there's
other methods that they can use and i
would really like to believe
that this really kind of goes back to
hydra right that it really all just
goes back to hydra itself it's one of
the things that i've kind of theorized
as a way to basically bring in
or bring in a wolverine into the mcu but
we know that like hydra had secretly
taken over shield
and so it wouldn't be that far outside
the realm of possibility that what you
had was hydra who was finding
trying to find a way to duplicate the
the super soldiers here from captain
america and seems to have succeeded
because that never happened in marvel
comics nobody was ever
ever able to perfectly duplicate the
super soldier serum of
steve rogers in anybody else the only
exception of that really was
isaiah now isaiah was introduced much
later on right 2003 is when he was first
introduced to marvel comics and so it
was the first time that marvel was like
no they duplicated
they duplicated steve rogers and they
basically made isaiah out of him and
then locked him away but you know we've
never really seen that happen on like a
large scale where you have like
dozens and dozens if even possibly you
know a few hundred people depending on
how big the flag smasher movement is
that all have super soldier
super soldier serum enhancements the big
question is where are they getting it
from
that's the big question who's giving it
to them where are they getting this
serum from i honestly have no clue i
really don't have an answer to that
question but in any event with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end this is uh this was a
great episode of hype train
and i will catch you all later
peace
you